[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend das thema ist brisant der
zeitpunkt mindestens unglücklich
vielleicht sogar teuflisch olaf scholz
derzeit spitzenreiter im rennen ums
kanzleramt und immer noch als
kabinettsmitglied
verantwortlich für alles was im
finanzministerium gerade und was
schiefläuft musste sich heute sechs tage
vor der wahl einer hochnotpeinlichen
befragung im finanzausschuss des
bundestages stellen es geht um
verdachtsmomente dass eine nachgeordnete
behörde seines hauses ermittlungen in
einem internationalen fall von
geldwäsche verschleppt oder
vereitelt habe ein verdacht den die
staatsanwaltschaft in osnabrück so
dringend fand dass sie die polizei
schickte um im ministerium und behörde
nach beweisen zu suchen
das riecht nicht gut aber es gibt auch
entgegengesetzten geruch weil der chef
der ford ermittelnden staatsanwaltschaft
ein gut vernetzter mann der cdu ist
genug buchstäblich fragwürdiges in beide
richtungen also heute im ausschuss
berichtet frank buchwald
er kam dann doch olaf scholz heute früh
im finanzausschuss viele abgeordnete
hatten damit nicht gerechnet dass der
minister sich nur digital zu schaltet
das nehmen wir zur kenntnis wir hätten
uns gewünscht wer persönlich hier war er
dann auch überraschung gelungen dann
aber muss scholz ich grillen lassen was
drei stunden lange baum steht ein höchst
unangenehmer verdacht
haben vorgaben aus berlin zu riesigen
lücken bei der geldwäschebekämpfung
geführt ist deutschland ein land in dem
es rechtsfreie räume gibt gerade bei der
bekämpfung schwerster kriminalität im
fadenkreuz die financial intelligence
unit kurz faq eine ermittlungsbehörde im
zollkriminalamt sie untersteht dem spd
geführten
finanzministerium ihr job geldwäsche
aufdecken kriminelle finanzströme
trockenlegen sie gilt jedoch als
ineffektiv und unterbesetzt auch wenn
scholz die behörde personell zuletzt
deutlich verstärkt hat
beamte der fa user der vorwurf säulen
geldwäscheverdachts meldungen nicht an
polizei und justiz weitergeleitet haben
ermittler der staatsanwaltschaft hatten
deshalb büros im finanzministerium
durchsucht und akten mitgenommen der
minister jedoch nimmt seine behörde in
schutz auch heute vor dem ausschuss ich
habe die gelegenheit genutzt noch einmal
zu erläutern dass wahrscheinlich die
letzten drei jahre die besten jahre
waren für die
aufstellung unserer behörden im hinblick
auf die bekämpfung von geldwäsche und
terrorismusfinanzierung
wir haben mehr hingekriegt in den
letzten drei jahren als in den letzten
30 jahren die opposition nicht überzeugt
viele fragen seien offen geblieben
beklagen fdp und grüne es ist jetzt
nicht gerne gekommen und die spd war es
auch nicht begeistert aber steht eben
nach wie vor im raum dass die behörde
falsch gearbeitet hat klar ist dass olaf
scholz seine behörde nicht im griff hat
das ist auch nicht die einzige behörde
anscheinend scheint unsere verwaltung
den vielfältigen aufgaben und damit auch
die politik in italien nicht mehr
gewachsen zu sein und dafür ist der
minister nun an allererster stelle
verantwortlich armin laschet scholz
rivale im kampf ums kanzleramt am abend
im heute-journal update vorwürfe aus der
spd die staatsanwaltschaft habe den
minister aus politischen gründen im
visier der cdu chef zurück scholz müsse
geldwäsche deutlich entschieden da
angehen da sind viele nebelkerzen
geworfen worden wir haben ein problem
mit der aufsicht bei olaf scholz es ist
nicht das erste mal dass er die dinge
nicht im griff hat und deshalb wird die
arbeit des ausschusses weitergehen der
noch vizekanzler lässt solche kritik ab
herren überraschung im ausschuss
gelungen ein paar termine im wahlkampf
hat scholz deshalb absagen müssen das
war es ihm wert sechs tage noch dann ist
das rennen gelaufen
der abgeordnete fabio de masi
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der linken ist ein über parteigrenzen
hinweg respektiert fachmann für die
finanzwelt und bei der verfolgung
dunkler und triebe dort guten abend herr
die maße
von handwerklicher ihnen der fdp und den
grünen war es ja sehr wichtig dass diese
befragung heute stattfand was hat es
denn gebracht
na ja wir haben erneut festgestellt wie
die letzten vier jahre auch dass wir ein
großes problem mit geldwäsche und
finanzkriminalität in deutschland haben
dass unsere behörde dafür die financial
intelligence unit kurz view nicht gut
aufgestellt ist ich fühle mich bestätigt
dass wir eine echte finanzpolizei in
deutschland brauchen aber wir kommen
auch etwas aufklären warum es diese doch
außergewöhnliche durchsuchungen auch gab
beziehungsweise den besuch der polizei
im finanzministerium na was war das denn
denn offensichtlich geht herr scholz
heute stolz erhobenen hauptes und
unbeschädigt aus dieser vernehmung des
ausschusses hinaus es ist so dass er
doch eingeräumt wird das ist ein
gespräch mit der staatsanwaltschaft gab
wo man sich darüber verständigt habe
dass einige schriftstücke dort gesichert
werden sollen das war wohl vor doch
nicht ganz klar und es gab ja auch ein
protestschreiben des spd geführten
justizministeriums und da ging es um den
sogenannten risikobasierten ansatz also
dass man dieser fülle von
verdachtsmeldungen die die vier bekommt
risiko schwerpunkte setzt das erst mal
völlig normal und auch in ordnung aber
das ist dabei wohl häufiger dazu kommt
dass bestimmte hinweise auf straftaten
gar nicht mehr weitergeleitet werden
denken wir den wirecard skandal wenn es
ein bilanzmanipulation ging hatte vier
gesagt wir leiten das gar nicht mehr
weiter ja allerdings aber wenn die
staatsanwaltschaft in einem ministerium
geht und nach dokumenten sucht die
offensichtlich man nicht einfach sich so
mal über telefon oder e-mail von einer
anderen behörde besorgen kann dann
stehen doch ganz andere vorwürfe im raum
dass etwa das ministerium grob
fahrlässig oder vielleicht sogar
vorsätzlich die eine oder andere
untersuchung geld für the ship
hintertreibt das stand im raum und steht
da jetzt nicht mehr
nein es gab eine beschwerde das ist eben
von einem kollegen des swr es auch noch
einmal veröffentlicht wurden es gab eine
sehr scharfe beschwerde des
justizministeriums wonach das
justizministerium spd geführt übrigens
von einer ministerin die schuhe
parlamentarischen staatssekretären von
olaf scholz war die haben die sorge
gehabt dass durch diesen neuen ansatz
des finanzministeriums straftaten in
deutschland nicht mehr weitergeleitet
werden das haben die so gesehen und
diese sorge hat die staatsanwaltschaft
offenbar geteilt das ist nicht
ausgeräumt denn oder scholz hat gesagt
sie hätten auf diese beschwerde des
justizministeriums geantwortet er wollte
uns aber die antwort heute noch nicht
zur verfügung stellen müssen das prüfen
ob er das kann olaf show sei dann aber
alle ich wollte das ist unbestritten
dass in seiner amtszeit die belegschaft
dieser finanzpolizei wenn man das so
nennen will
verdreifacht worden ist und damit auch
die kapazitäten also wie passt das zu
ihrem vorwurf von vernachlässigungen
diese aufgabe
das ist absolut richtig dass mehr
stellen geschaffen wurden das ist aber
auch völlig normal weil jedes jahr immer
mehr geldwäsche verdachtsmeldung
abgeliefert werden dadurch die
gesetzgebung das ist auch normal dass
man bei den stellen nachlegt was aber
nicht richtig ist ist dass er eine art
finanzpolizei haben wir haben eben keine
das ist ja das problem herr schäuble
damals die anti geldwäsche behörde von
boris kanal am zum zoll verlegt und wir
haben gerade nicht wie zum beispiel in
italien eine echte finanzpolizei mit
journalistischer expertise das heißt es
bringt nichts einfach immer nur mehr
stellen zu schaffen wir brauchen die
richtigen leute
es reicht nicht nur auf künstliche
intelligenz zu setzen wir brauchen auch
natürliche intelligenz also
kriminalistische spürnasen und die haben
wir nicht deswegen muss nach meiner
überzeugung die geldwäschebekämpfung
herr ausgelagert werden aus dem zoll und
wir brauchen eine übergreifende
finanzpolizei wurden vom zoll dabei sind
aber eben auch aus den
landeskriminalämtern und dafür musste
jetzt heute sechs tage vor der wahl
diese berliner bühne zur verfügung
stehen für eine vernehmung des
finanzministers und kanzlerkandidaten
übrigens das einzigen kanzlerkandidaten
der ihrer partei wenigstens einen
schatten von hoffnung gibt vielleicht an
der nächsten regierung beteiligt zu sein
naja ich kann ja jetzt nicht
aufführungen die richtigen fragen zu
stellen also ich bin seit vier jahren
mit diesem thema immer wieder in
verbindung gebracht das auch wenn kein
wahlkampf ist auch wenn ich nicht
eingeladen werde in nachrichtensendungen
habe ich mich immer wieder damit
beschäftigt das heißt ich bin da ganz
entspannt mir kann keiner vorwerfen ich
würde irgendein wahlkampf getragen ich
trete ja auch gar nicht mehr zur wahl an
sondern ich sorge mich darum dass wir in
deutschland ein paradies für geldwäsche
und finanzkomitee sind das ist nicht nur
meine meinung das ist die meinung zum
beispiel das anti mafia staatsanwalt von
palermo roberto scarpinato der sagt wäre
er immer für so würde in deutschland
investieren und dieses problem mag herr
scholz geerbt haben von herrn schäuble
aber er war eben ein kanzlerkandidat im
wartestand und er wollte sich nicht
wirklich damit beschäftigen außer dass
er eben ein paar stellen mehr geschaffen
hat und das fällt ihm jetzt auf die füße
das habe ich mir nicht ausgesucht und es
hat auch niemand etwas davon in
deutschland wenn ich herrn scholz jetzt
schon an dieser stelle das macht
übrigens auch die linke nicht stärker
und damit auch nicht die
wahrscheinlichkeit einer rot rot grünen
koalition
die einschätzung eines fachmanns der
dieses fach nun aufgibt und sich von der
politik erst mal verabschiedet
dankeschön hatten sie einen schönen
namen
ich danke
das gespräch hatten wir vor einer stunde
am ende des tages hat wesel im journal
update dann noch mehr fragen an armin
laschet auftakt einer reihe in den
updates dieser woche vor der wahl immer
am ende des tages letzte fragen an die
sechs
spitzenkandidat
für die linkspartei deren
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
herr fabio de masi noch ist wird der
nächste sonntag noch ein bisschen
spannender als für alle anderen im
bundestag
weil nämlich die spannweite der
möglichkeiten für die linken noch größer
ist es ist nicht ausgeschlossen dass sie
an der fünf prozent klausel scheitern
und aus dem bundestag rausfliegen es
könnte andererseits aber auch sein dass
ein gewisser olaf scholz sie doch noch
als koalitionspartner braucht weil ihm
lindner fdp
die roten flügel zu sehr stützen will
andrea maurer beobachtet linksaußen eine
partei zwischen chancen und gefahren
bitterfeld sachsen-anhalt die verluste
die strukturwandel mit sich bringt sind
hier sichtbar die industrialisierung
nach der wende abwanderung es ist der
wahlkreis von ihren konnte kein leichter
mehr für die linke viele wähler sind
gestorben viele arbeiter wählen jetzt
afd korte kämpft wenn du was bewegen
willst gerade hier in der region musst
du auch den kopf und den bauch der leute
erreichen und das bedeutet zuspitzen
noch mal deutlich zu sagen was man will
und zum anderen glaube ich ist wichtig
natürlich noch mal zu sagen was ist
eigentlich die perspektive für die linke
wofür sie dort wo für ist die linken es
geht auch um die existenz der partei die
spitze ist heute nach bitterfeld
gekommen mit ihren versprechen
mindestlohn von 13 euro kinder
grundsicherung anpassung der ost-renten
politikwechsel
ortswechsel bankenstadt frankfurt am
main hier im westen hat sich die linke
verjüngt in akademischen milieus
ausgedehnt und bleibt doch der
fünf-prozent-hürde gefährlich nah die
partei macht hier zweikampf mit dem
linksrutsch vor dem union und fdp warnen
wenn spd und grüne es ernst meinen mit
mehr sozialer gerechtigkeit und mit
klimaschutz dann dürfen sie doch nicht
mit fdp und union regieren und die linke
staaten angreifen 80 prozent der
mitglieder wollen dass die linke regiert
die parteispitze will es auch seit
monaten bereitet parteichefin hennig
welt so sondierungsgespräche vor dazu
gehört innerparteilichen streit
schlichten auftritt mit dem linken
promi-paar lafontaine und wagenknecht in
weimar vor monaten undenkbar dazu
gehören auch rot rote signale auftritt
janine wissler und saskia esken zum
thema kinderarmut im wahlkampf ist das
botschaft essen macht klar dass ihr
programm auch das von scholz ist
dieses zukunftsprogramm ist wie gesagt
gemeinsam erarbeitet worden also auf
grundlage dessen die wir dann in
koalitionsverhandlungen gehen werden
eine widersprüchliche botschaft zum
spd-kanzlerkandidaten der die linken
maximal auf distanz hält denn es gibt
auch dieses signal dass selbst essen das
falsche nennt 43 linke abgeordnete
enthalten sich beim evakuierungs mandat
für afghanistan
sie bestimmen mit nein es geht um die
verlässlichkeit der partei die linke im
verteidigungs- modus
das ist funktional für den wahlkampf ich
finde es unverantwortlich dass man uns
dieses vorwirft die linke ist
verlässlich wir haben gegen das
afghanistan mandat von anfang an
gestimmt wir sehen in welchem desaster
das geändert ist in bitterfeld frage
kein arbeiter der morgens zur schicht
fährt ob deutschland noch in der nato
sei sagt jan korte es ist die erzählung
auf die sich die parteispitze geeinigt
hat wenn die linke mitregieren und die
soziale lage der menschen verbessern
könnte darf sie sich zumindest in der
frage nato ja oder nein nicht verkämpfen
nachrichten nun von gunda lag aus in
russland hat sich die partei von
präsident putin nach 18 jahren an der
macht erneut zum sieger ausrufen lassen
trotz manipulationsvorwürfen die
russische opposition erklärte die wahl
sei massiv gefälscht worden
unabhängige wahlbeobachter hatten mehr
als 4000 verstöße registriert in sankt
petersburg kam es bei einer wahl
kontrolle zu rangeleien im vergleich zur
letzten wahl hat die partei geeintes
russland ein minus von knapp 45 prozent
zu verzeichnen dennoch hat die
kreml-partei nach behördenangaben erneut
die absolute mehrheit erreicht mehr als
300 der 450 sitze
die staatsanwaltschaft konstanz hat das
ermittlungsverfahren gegen afc
spitzenkandidatin weidl in der
parteispendenaffäre
eingestellt strafbar sei eine auf
stückelung von spenden zur
verschleierung für die empfängerin nur
wenn diese daran mitgewirkt habe dafür
habe sich in wedels fall kein
ausreichender verdacht ergeben es ging
um spenden aus der schweiz um von
132.000 euro an weidens kreisverband das
geld wurde 2018 zurückgezahlt
vollständig gegen korona geimpfte
ausländer können ab anfang november
wieder in die usa einreisen
außerdem müssen sie einen maximal drei
tage alten negativen corona test
vorlegen den einreise stopp hatte zu
beginn der pandemie im märz 2020 der
damalige präsident trump angeordnet die
pharmaunternehmen biontech und weise
wollen schnellstmöglich die zulassung
ihres corona impfstoffes für fünf bis
elfjährige kinder beantragen ersten
studienergebnissen zufolge sei der
impfstoff in dieser altersgruppe gut
verträglich und wirksam
deutschlandweit ist die sieben tage
incidents wieder leicht angestiegen auf
71 leicht gesunken ist dagegen die
hospitalisierung rate die zahl der
korona bedingten krankenhauseinweisungen
der letzten sieben tage auf
1,65 pro 100.000 einwohner
in thüringen ist heute feiertag
arbeitsfrei thüringen ist das einzige
deutsche bundesland das den
weltkindertag heute so schön begeht man
muss ja nicht unbedingt feiern man kann
auch was für die sache tun deutschland
bräuchte das weil hier noch immer noch
stärker als in anderen hoch entwickelten
ländern die zukunftschancen der kinder
abhängen vom einkommen der eltern das
ist nicht nur zutiefst ungerecht es ist
eiskalt gerechnet auch eine vergeudung
von ressourcen
solche dinge nicht in abgehobenen
politischen debatten sondern in der
wirklichkeit zu zeigen das ist der zweck
von
zdf so nennen wir langzeit einsätze von
zdf reporterinnen und reportern in einer
stadt oder region zurzeit nicht in
thüringen in frankfurt oder wo die
sorgen von eltern und kindern noch
drängender sind als anderswo antje
klingbeil ist dort
gleich wird lara mit den anderen auf der
bühne stehen vorbereitungen für einen
lang ersehnt nur auftritt
ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt
rund 200 kinder musizieren und tanzen
bei der fanfaren gerade im größten
musikverein in frankfurt an der oder und
man kann ja auch sehr viele freunde
finde ich echt cool dass ich doch
manchmal feste machen so wie heute zum
weltkindertag viele die hier im verein
spielen kommen aus familien die
armutsgefährdet sind gemeinsam mit 30
ehrenamtlich engagierten leitet hans
jörg laurich das orchester
über den musik rahmen hinaus versuchen
wir mit kindern ja erfolgserlebnis so zu
schaffen dass die kinder gemeinschaft
spüren wie es ist ja gemeinsam ein ziel
zu verfolgen
frankfurt oder eine der
einkommensschwächsten kommunen
deutschlands seit der wende ohne große
industrie der billiglohnsektor wohnt die
folge familien und kinderarmut jedes
dritte kind ist betroffen was wir
dringend brauchen es
chancengerechtigkeit dass kinder die ja
völlig unverschuldet in diese situation
gekommen sind im alltag das nicht zu
spüren bekommen sondern die gleichen
zugänge zu allen angeboten erhalten
damit sie ihr leben auch so entwickeln
können wie andere kinder auch bei der
fanfaren garde kostet der monatsbeitrag
15 euro für eltern die sich das nicht
leisten können gibt es das bildungs und
teilhabepaket doch das zu beantragen
fällt vielen schwer was wir fordern dass
also die bürokratie gerade für die
teilhabe von kindern und jugendlichen
gesenkt wird alle hier in frankfurt auch
pädagogen sozialarbeiter oder eltern
haben große erwartungen an die politik
die kinderbetreuung auf jeden fall
kostenlos zu machen und auch jeden
bereit zu stellen dann muss eben ja die
bildung eine höhere priorität bekommen
vielmehr institutionen schaffen wo
kinder auffangen werden grundsätzlich
müssen kinder wie eine größere rolle
spielen
sowie beim heutigen kinder fest wo sie
im mittelpunkt stehen das macht auch
spaß wieder so zusammen zu sein
bald gibt es sicher auch wieder
ferienlager und konzertreisen hier
können sich alle kinder ausprobieren und
entwickeln unabhängig von ihrer herkunft
so soll es sein das ist ja nicht
verkehrt wenn sich deutschland in einem
wahljahr größere sorgen um zu hause
macht um soziale probleme bildung und
zukunft also um ferne welt konflikte die
machen dafür nur keine pause das
westliche bündnis ist gerade in einem
gewaltigen stresstest im epizentrum
im westen des pazifischen ozeans wo die
usa traditionell mit bestimmten trotz
riesiger entfernung der anspruch der
alten weltmacht kennt auf erden keine
grenzen china will das nicht mehr
akzeptieren sieht sich selbst in der
vormacht dort präsident biden hat gegen
peking ein neues bündnis geschmiedet mit
australien auf der einen und der alten
semak großbritannien auf der fernen
anderen seite das erste opfer dieses
manövers ist nicht peking sondern
frankreich der erste gewinner
großbritannien diana zimmermann
berichtet aus london
so gefällt es boris johnson große bühne
wichtiger auftritt es ist des britischen
premiers zweite un vollversammlung in
new york und die gelegenheit brachse
briten international groß rauszubringen
doch wer neue bündnisse geschmiedet tut
alten freunden wie johnson musste heute
einmal mehr frankreich beschwichtigen
es gibt nur ein einziges land in der
welt mit dem wir ein programm für
atomtest simulationen haben und dieses
land ist frankreich großbritannien und
frankreich haben eine sehr sehr wichtige
beziehung eine unzerstörbare beziehung
anlass für diese worte ist der
vergangene woche geschlossene
sicherheitsteam mit australien und den
usa er dient dazu australien sicherer zu
machen in erster linie richtet er sich
gegen die chinesen die im indopazifik
immer dreister auftreten und auf das
neue bündnis entsprechend sauer
reagierten
china verfolgt wirtschaftliche
kooperation unter regionale integration
während die usa großbritannien und
australien krieg und zerstörung führen
das war eingepreist denn der neue
verteidigungsminister
demonstrativer schritt hin zu einer
deutlich aggressiveren anti china
politik amerika konzentriert sich auch
den indopazifik großbritannien geht mit
und auf distanz zur eu die europäer
müssen viel mehr tun um ihren eigenen
hinterhof sicher zu halten das gilt mit
blick auf russland das gilt auch mit
blick auf den süden und hier brauchen
wir großbritannien sei es in der nato
sei es vielleicht auch in kooperation
mit der eu wobei die johnson regierung
sich das skeptisch zeigt vor allem die
franzosen aber fühlen sich jetzt
verraten der neue pakt bahnte sich schon
beim g7-gipfel in cornwall
ansonsten beiden und morrison diskret
über u boote sprachen während emanuel
makro sich lauthals über den dragset
ärgerte nun ärgert er sich noch viel
mehr in frankreich wurde ausgebootet
stadt einen viele milliarden euro
schweren vertrag mit paris einzuhalten
wollen die australier lieber u boote von
den amerika und den briten die nuclear
betrieben werden und noch heimlicher
arbeiten können der britische
verteidigungsminister wurde heute
kurzerhand von militärischen
konsultationen in paris ausgeladen es
ist eine nie dagewesene krise zwischen
den beiden europäischen atommächte mit
ausnahmsweise großbritannien am längeren
hebel ich glaube dass sich
großbritannien ganz geschickt
positioniert hat weil im bereich
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
großbritannien sehr viele fähigkeiten
hat auf die die eu europäer auch schauen
oder mit dass die der drang mit
großbritannien zusammenzuarbeiten ist
weiterhin groß auch trotz des exit je
nach lage will global briten neue
bündnisse schließen oder alter ausbauen
beim handel funktioniert das
rosinenpicken bislang nicht kein grund
ist in der verteidigung nicht weiter zu
versuchen
die lufthansa hat vorbereitungen für die
rückzahlung der staatshilfen in höhe von
25 milliarden euro getroffen dazu will
der luftfahrtkonzern neue aktien von gut
2,1 milliarden euro ausgeben mit der
geplanten tilgung wäre die lufthansa das
erste großunternehmen dass die korona
hilfen des bundes zurückzahlt
konzernchef spur begründet das vorhaben
auch mit den anziehenden nachfrage
die lufthansa aktie legte daraufhin
ordentlich zu gegen den trend heute der
dax verlor deutlich und das in einem
premieren tag erstmals in seiner mehr
als 30 jährigen geschichte umfasst der
deutsche aktienindex 40 unternehmen
frank bethmann die deutsche wirtschaft
soll damit besser abgebildet werden ist
das gelungen nur bedingt die
gesundheitssparte ist gestärkt worden
mit gleich drei neuen siemens hält
turniers kia gehen und sartorius mit
zalando und den koch boxen lieferanten
helau fresh wird der dax etwas moderner
ja aber der ganz große wurf ist es nicht
wie auch dafür sind unter den neulingen
mit ausnahme von airbus doch eher nur
leichtgewichte nach der dennoch bisher
größten reform seiner geschichte
verliert der dax heute übertragen 50
punkte und fällt auf den niedrigsten
stand seit zwei monaten einen strich
durch die rechnung macht der chinesische
immobilienkonzern ever grant investoren
verkauften aktien weil sie die
zahlungsunfähigkeit des giganten
befürchten schon wird darüber spekuliert
ob der krisenkonzern das chinesische
lehman brothers sei der zusammenbruch
der amerikanischen investmentbank löste
2008 die globale finanzkrise aus so dick
muss es nicht gleich kommen doch die
angst vor einer ausgewachsenen
immobilienkrise ist groß insgesamt also
heute schlechtes timing für den neuen
dax der sich sicherlich einen besseren
start erhofft hatte frank bethmann
vielen dank
zum auftakt der herbstvollversammlung
der katholischen deutschen
bischofskonferenz hat deren vorsitzender
bischof bätzing konkretes handeln
angekündigt die menschen sollten merken
dass sich wesentliches verändere sagte
er in bezug auf den innerkirchlichen
reformprozess synodaler weg über den die
bischöfe beraten weiterer schwerpunkt
wird die aufarbeitung der fälle von
sexualisierter gewalt sein möglichst
bald solle über die angekündigten
entschädigungen für missbrauchsopfer
beraten werden
auf der kanaren insel la palma wälzen
sich nach dem vulkanausbruch
gigantische glühende lavaströme richtung
meer sie hinterlassen eine spur der
zerstörung und 100 häuser sind bereits
von der lava überrollt durch
umfangreiche evakuierungen wurden opfer
verhindert mehr als 5000 anwohner der
dünn besiedelten region und touristen
hatten sich in sicherheit gebracht
spaniens ministerpräsident sánchez sagte
auf la palma schnelle hilfe zu experten
wollen sich nicht festlegen wie lange
der vulkanausbruch dauern wird
möglicherweise seien es monate
schlimmes geschehen großartige bilder
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen schönen
abend an dem sich gegen mitternacht wulf
schmiese mit unserem heute-journal
update meldet
[Musik]
jetzt hat das azorenhoch mal einen namen
bekommen das hoch kerstin es wird für
uns interessant denn es bildet eine
brücke zu dem hof genie das tiefe roland
hat inzwischen moskau erreicht und das
-tief tim das sieht morgen hier weiter
über island und dieses tief hat noch
abstand zu uns aber die nächsten tiefs
die nachfolgen die könnten dann
tatsächlich mal mitteleuropa erreichen
in der zweiten wochenhälfte nicht in
dieser nacht da bleibt alles ruhig
höchstens an der ostsee kann es mal ein
bisschen tröpfeln wenn die wolken
aufreißen dann bildet sich rasch nebel
und da wird es sehr kalt in den mulden
lagen der mittelgebirge droht sogar
bodenfrost in der luft sinken die
temperaturen auf 9 bis 4 grad milder
bleibt die nacht am oberrhein oder auch
an der nordsee mit zehn oder zwölf grad
und zwölf grad sind am morgen eine
höchsttemperatur jedenfalls hier in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen
sonst liegen die höchstwerte meist um
die 16 grad von der nordseeküste bis zum
oberrhein sind es dagegen 8 10 bis 20
grad und auch morgen bleibt es im
nordosten meist stark bewölkt bis
bedeckt da tut sich die sonne schwer und
allenfalls hier an der ost- oder nordsee
kann es auch mal für ein bisschen
regenreichen aber sehr viel wird das
nicht richtung südwesten ist es deutlich
freuen sich ja da macht sich das hoch
castingshow bemerkbar und an diesem
wetter ändert sich am mittwoch noch
wenig da fällt dann am ehesten richtung
sachsen und südliches brandenburg etwas
regen aber am donnerstag könnte es dann
für den ersten herbststurm an der
nordseeküste reichen guten abend